just informal
if you want to be a little bit more
formal you can say
what well we're not going to bed yet
you're saying you're going to die
is
today is an important day in italy
because it's the beginning
of carne vale
carnevales is carnival i think you are
familiar
originally italy the celebration of
carnival was the celebration
of the end of the winter and the
beginning of the spring
it should be much later here in boston
it's not usually february
in italy usually middle of february is a
good time when it starts to get warmer
and
it's not spring but it's the beginning
so carne vale is carnival
it starts today and it will end on
tuesday
next tuesday tuesday is
martini today and we call
this specific tuesday
means fats
yeah it's fat tuesday so why is fat
tuesday
well because typically we would eat very
very fat
food and you have some examples
here these are some typical sweets that
we eat for carnevale
they're both deep fried so we're not
going to do them they're not
particularly healthy
but if you want the recipe i need you
the recipe anyway
they're very very tasty the idea is that
this celebration was initially a pagan
celebration
and then it became a christian
celebration
like a huge party where everything
or almost everything is allowed
before the beginning of juarez
had lent that is a period where
period more of any turns a period where
many
many people decide for example to let go
of some luxuries of some things they
like
so it's like the last huge party you can
eat everything in fact and afterwards
maybe you decide oh
i'm gonna diet i'm not going to eat
anything so for carnivale
carnival people usually wear costumes
kind of like halloween here and mostly
kids
like it's very unusual that you walk
anywhere in italy and you find everybody
in costume
but well there are like kids especially
and there are some parties and
there are some i'm sorry for the quality
but you have a printout actually of the
macbook
and there are some huge huge
celebrations
the most famous are the carnivale of
diarrhea girl is in tuscany
there is carnevale ibrea
ibrea is in
and for the carnivale of the apart from
wearing costumes there is also a very
famous
bottle with oranges people throw
oranges if you google it you see the
images is really really
something and then probably the most
famous carnival
in italy is incarnate venezia
venice there it is
so in venezuela
there are a lot of parades and there are
some
characteristic costumes traditional
costumes so you should enjoy carnevale
during the weekend you have a long
weekend for a different reason
but okay enjoy nevada until
tuesday until because afterwards
we can't celebrate anymore so let's try
to
review what you did the idea is this
each of you can stand up
look at the others and say ciao
you say your name and then just
tell us something that you remember from
last week
it can be anything that could it can be
another sentence
it could be even just the way that you
pronounce the letter a
that's uh okay you can come here and say
hey ciao
we say oh
the vowels
ciao michael mcclara
uh
our second lesson and
i can ask each of you
let's do it one word at a time you
remember
omit the subject too because it's not
that important
unless i really want to emphasize then i
would i would say so i start from here
let's do another round we can ask
each other where do we come from and you
can say i come from
wherever you come from i said milano i'm
not exactly from
milan i'm from a small town close to
milan
on big lake that's the largest lake in
italy
named lake
lagos
but i think that most of you come from
this unity
let's say
that would
if you have a feminine it could be
so texas is not a city
it's a state so you put the article and
you say
vengo dal texas
texas
yeah so now you know how to introduce
yourself
how to say where you come from
let me look around
is
yeah so we are trying to learn
demonstrative objectives so in english
you have this that these
those let's start with the singular
in italian we have questo
code
okay you see they all end with an o so
that's
masculine how come that we have three
choices
instead of just two this and that well
questo means this and it's something
that is close to me
when i'm talking about something that's
close to me
is something that is far from me but is
close to you it's not really very common
you won't hear it when you talk to the
other
italian unless he or he comes from
tuscany
then there is a chance that they will
use podesta
but from now on we will just stick to
cuesto
for that so in principle is when it's
far from
both of us so as i told you already last
time
in italian we conjugate everything so
if an adjective refers to a noun that's
feminine
or masculine the ending changes
so in english you would say
this onion and
this book
in italian i would say questo
foreign
if it's masculine it becomes questi
and if it's feminine it becomes quest
question
and now you can try to read without me
what's going on
with that and those
so let's see what i told you earlier
questa questions
i forgot
adjective similar
okay
is bigger
d that would be
then
what
itself
since we want to go ahead and learn
how to say la let's see
exactly where this word come from sulla
is a composition of
soup that means on
and
that would be the article
and then we just put them together and
it becomes
okay so take it some time and try you
can discuss you can do this together
try to come out with some new ten
sentences involving
the adjectivity and some of the words
that you already know
let me write it down
people look at you like where do you
come from
united states
we put an apostrophe that little sign is
an apostrophe
you can say questions
so yeah one way to refer to apples and
pears
is to call them homie
typically if you are talking about this
fruit
then you say you call it milan
so this fruit is mela
and i can say mela
with me
well i actually have two oh
yeah so it was questa now i have two
questions
when we have only one cuesta
who wants to write the nest
very good
so you see we don't add an s like in
english to make the plural
we change the ending of the word
we also
next time we will actually conjugate the
whole verb to be
in the present okay
good
so tonight we're going to cook a dish
that's typical from northern italy
it's called risotto
you